throughout our lives we spend a lot of
time and even more money engineering
Pleasant experiences we booked airline
tickets visit beaches admire glaciers
say hello to penguins watch elephants
drinking and so on in all this the
emphasis is almost always on the
experience itself which lasts a certain
amount of time and then is over the idea
of making a big deal of revisiting an
experience in memory sounds a little
strange or simply sad we're not a
situated cultivators of our past
experiences we shove all the nice things
that have happened to us at the back of
the cupboard of our minds and don't
particularly expect to see them ever
again they happen and then we're done
with them they do sometimes come back to
us unbidden we may be on a boring train
ride to work and suddenly an image of a
beach at dusk comes to life or while
we're having a bath
we remember climbing a flower covered
mountain with a friend a decade before
but little attention tends to get paid
to such moments we don't engineer
regular encounters with them we may feel
we have to dismiss them as daydreaming
or thinking about nothing but what if we
were to alter the hierarchy of prestige
a little and argue that regular
immersion in our memories is a critical
part of what can sustain and console us
and not least is perhaps the cheapest
and most flexible form of entertainment
we should learn regularly to travel
around our minds and think it almost as
prestigious to sit at home and reflect
on a trip we once took to an island as
to track to this island encased in our
cumbersome bodies in on a glint of our
memories we are spoiled children who
squeeze only a portion of the pleasure
from our experiences and then toss them
aside to seek new thrills part of why we
feel the need for so many new
experiences may simply be that we're so
bad at absorbing the ones we've had to
help us focus more in our memories we
need nothing technical we certainly
don't need a camera there is a camera in
our minds already and it's always on it
takes everything we've ever seen huge
chunks of experience are still there in
our heads intact and
it just waiting for us to ask ourselves
leading questions like where did we go
after we landed or what was the first
breakfast like when we can't sleep when
there's no Wi-Fi we should always think
of going on memory journeys our
experiences have not disappeared just
because they're no longer unfolding
right in front of our eyes we can remain
in touch with so much of what made them
pleasurable simply through the art of a
vocation we talk endlessly a virtual
reality yet we don't need gadgets we
have the finest virtual reality machines
already in our own heads we can right
now shut our eyes and travel into and
linger amongst the very best and most
consoling and life-enhancing bits of our
past
you